okay let's talk about this audition
because you walk in
and no audience right like agents doing
a very unique thing they've never done
it before because of the
because of the pandemic so did that help
nerves not having a crowd like what was
your reaction to no audience being there
well it's kind of one of those things
that
when i walked out you don't know how
you're going to feel until you walk out
you know
um because it's usually an auditorium
that sits 3 000 people that's
right and then you have three judges so
part of me is like okay well this is
kind of cool i have
just the three of them just their three
out like attention and everything like
that
um and then on the flip side of it
it's it's kind of like you're you see
this on tv this whole production of
having a huge audience and you're kind
of writing off with their energy
um kind of thing so it was a little
different having
no crowd but at the same time it was
kind of fun having just the attention of
the judges
as you're sitting there performing for
them um and it's one of those things
that i mean i've
played at places where i've i played for
a few people in a room
um and i played at places where there's
a handful of people
and so whether or not it's three
thousand or three
people you kind of want to make sure you
make the best of it
and treat it the same way you know right
right
now yeah then you nail your audition
song but then simon gets you to stop
and says sing acapella so what's going
through your head
when he says that to you yeah so
it was one of those things as soon as he
stopped me he raised his hand and then
right it's surreal because you usually
only see this when you're
watching it on tv and i'm like oh
goodness so
like every thought floods my mind you
know um and i'm like he's gonna
tell me you know thank you but no thank
you
try again next year kind of thing and
then that that was like the first thing
that came to my mind so as soon as he
said
you know we just i really want you to
prove what you are wanting to prove and
what you came out here to prove
um it kind of like i settled down a
little bit and so then he asked me to
sing
acapella and um sing that the christian
song that i sing as well
and i mean he is a man that knows the
industry in and out and
um has been around forever and i respect
him completely so
him asking me to stop and sing it
acapella
um was just i'm like
perfectly okay with that right and i
probably panicked until the moment the
first word came out of my mouth
um so i remember the feeling like it was
yesterday
um i definitely don't want to be don't
want to feel like that
but you know it was one of those things
that i
probably wouldn't have it any other way
and the man knows what he's doing and i
respect that completely so
it was it was the right decision because
you sounded amazing doing acapella too
so yeah it was awesome have you looked
at the reaction
to you being on the show because i know
detox gave you that message of
don't look at the comments so are you
somebody that's looked at comments
uh you know so i feel right before i got
that video sent to me
i was starting to go through comments
and
it's one of those things that i mean i
can take a comment
saying that you know they don't enjoy my
music or my voice and
you know it's it's one of those things
it comes with the territory and
um i'm completely okay with it um and
but at the same time it does kind of
discourage you you know
you're hoping that you're going to get
the best feedback but
it's not always that way um and it is
one of those things that you just kind
of
you don't take personal and receiving
that message from her was like
validation that
okay don't take everything personal um
it was super cool i still to this day
i'm very
um very almost like fan girl out
about getting that video because it's
super super cool and
her journey with everything has been
amazing on reality tv as well so
um i can only hope that i have part of
the success that
that she does yeah in terms of being a
fan of someone i know you said
when you went and saw shania twain
concert like you knew this is what you
wanted to do
what was it about shania or the concert
that you knew
i want to do that yeah so i remember the
concert like it was yesterday
so like the houston lifestyle showing
rodeo so i grew up in houston texas and
so
um it's like one of the biggest things
of the year so
i go every single year and that was like
my first year of going for many years
after that
and so i remember we were like
maybe five rows up and um
she started playing and my mom my mom
told me this one part that i ran
down to like because there's kind of
barriers there and kind of stood up on
the barrier because i'm nine years old
or
eight years old at this point and so um
i just remember the production
like her energy and then the crowds
energy and it's like it's one of those
things you feed off of each other and
um and just her voice of everything
because
definitely um this was goodness the 90s
so it was
really big prime time for shania as well
you know and so
the music of everything and it's just
everything came together where it was
like i
remember going back to my mom and
telling you like this is what i want to
do like how do i make it there
um and what do we need to do to get
there so
shortly after that my mom gave me a you
know we went through a few things with
um how we were gonna figure that all out
and so
it was just the beginning of many many
times that we had to travel and we're
going to sing but
ultimately that's one of my biggest
goals is to make it to that stage
because that was the first time i saw
her my first concert and then she just
became a huge role model of mine when it
came down to
the music industry in general so yeah
and then you started performing and then
you came out as gay and you alluded to
it on agt about
you know the reaction that you were
getting from people being a gay artist i
mean i've talked to a lot of
country music artists it seems like
unless you're a straight white male you
really struggle
in the country music industry in terms
of getting that recognition but yeah
what were
what was some of the backlashes what was
some of the bad reaction you were
getting to being a gay
country artist yeah so and
and during this time it was a time where
i was trying to figure it out as myself
and who i was as a person and then
it's just with the country music
industry it's a little conservative on
the side that
you know we've never seen a gay country
singer i mean ty hernan came out
once his career got started and he had
all that going and then
a few of the artists billy gilman and um
a few other artists in there as well and
so a lot of them will say that
you know their career was hurt after the
fact they came out you know
as being gay and so that was always in
the back of my mind that okay well
you know if i come out as being gay then
you know my career is just not going to
be the same as somebody who is straight
you know
um which it should i feel like it
shouldn't be like that
you know should be an equal kind of
chance there i mean talent is talent and
that's just kind of one of the things
that i see that
i don't want to be based off of being a
gay country singer you know i want to be
i want to be cameron ross for and known
for my voice and my music and you know
just being able to connect with people
musically and lyrically as well you know
um
and then there was times i remember
growing up and because i sang a lot in
east texas growing up so
um after school on a friday me and my
parents would pack up the car and drive
out do a gig and drive back that night
or
whatever it was that weekend kind of
thing and try to fit it in where we
could
and there were some times where when i
started to come out and come true to
like who i was as a person
um and coming to truce with all of that
that if certain venues found out like a
certain bar in a very
maybe religious or conservative town
that you know there was a chance that i
wasn't going to get booked there you
know
um that i might have sang there before
but coming back there might be not be
the deal
i remember going through hard times that
once people found out that they just
unfriended me when it came down to our
relationships there
and a lot of the time some of those
people did have to do
with some of my industry's success in
there and so
it was kind of something hard to
to chew there but at the same time it it
i was staying true to myself at the
moment you know um
and kind of loving who i was as a person
but still wanting to make sure that i
loved the part of my dream and still
pursued that right
and you said that it caused you to take
a break for a while what was the thing
that brought you back like what was that
ultimate decision of no i'm going to do
this
so i took a break just because
at the same time that music stuff i kind
of fell on the back burner
um i had some family situations that
took place
and and then me personally i wanted to
be a hundred percent with myself um and
so i kind of took a break to figure out
myself
and and do as much as i could kind of
self-development and
so kind of coming back it was just one
of those things that i
actually i think it was around 2016
maybe a little bit before that
my mid-20s my mid to late 20s and um
i there was a america's got talent
audition that came around
that i was like you know what like maybe
we should give this another one so then
i started writing a little bit more
again and
and um kind of singing where i could
all over again and at that time in my
life i'm
very very happy with who i was as a
person um
and very very comfortable and
you know i sing because i love it
and i write because i love it and if
i was to have a fame career
or one where i'm playing in bars on the
weekend
i do it because i love it you know at
the end of the day and i love having
that connection
with an audience or with an individual
um
through my music right so in terms of
getting back out there's just been great
you know yeah and in terms of
uh you know other not even just
musicians just young people in general
would you have any advice for people
that are
struggling to come out um you know
i definitely it's not i feel nowadays
it's something that you shouldn't be
afraid of
um you know as long as you're staying
true to yourself
um and doing what you love to do um
and if it's a dream much like mine not
not not put not on hold because of
something of being gay because i i feel
like people are a lot more accepting
nowadays especially
um and as we learn more and people that
we're educating more people and things
like that it's definitely
we've grown as a society and i think we
will continue to grow and
i just say do what makes you happy
you know when you're confident somebody
is comfortable
and they feel like it's time to come out
as being gay you'll know
i mean i knew when it was when i was
ready to be like okay you know what i'm
ready to tell my friend's family and
whoever if i was to be asked i'll
willingly say
um but to just not be afraid to be
yourself
and you know go for anything and
everything that you possibly can
yeah well said i mean so it's only been
a couple weeks since that audition aired
yes obviously your fan base is growing
like crazy do you have
an ultimate like duet partner that you'd
want to record with
oh goodness you know there's so many
i could name off a massive amount of
people
um but you know i
am a really big fan of old school
country like keith whitley
things like that um and you know not all
of them are
still around i would love to at one day
sing
you know but then i have you know george
straits from texas
and um i am a huge fan of king george
and so i have
casey musgraves who i grew up singing
with um at a few different places in
east texas
that is very
forward with the gay community and is
something to look up to when it comes
down to the country music industry and
how she's changing views in there you
know
um so i did i didn't feel like i
couldn't
it's a hard question to pin down right
you know
i definitely even like moving back to my
first concert like
i feel like shania twain is one of the
reasons why i got
everything started because her just
energy
her music her voice all of it just kind
of was like
you know this is it this is what i want
to do and
it's been many many years but um you
know it's all coming
it's all coming in full circle and
pulling together now and i couldn't be
more happier with how everything's
everything's taken place
yeah well that's awesome well
congratulations on that first audition i
can't wait to see
your journey on agt and then your
journey beyond that because i think
you're going to be a big star cameron
thank you so much we have judges next
week and so
i'm super super excited for that so
we'll see how all that goes and i just
can't wait to hear all the results for
all of that so
let's be really good fingers crossed